The fact is, the
vaccine push is on.
And if some companies can
sort of push that along,
well, they're all in, especially
what's going on at Krispy Kreme
right now, that
instituted a new policy.
If you can prove you've taken
at least one dose of a vaccine,
they'll give you a free donut.
So it seemed like a
perfectly good deal to me.
I would just go into one
Krispy Kreme after another,
repeatedly.
Get thousands of donuts
with the same proof.
Anyway.
What's happening now is the food
police are going after Krispy
Kreme, saying that this
is actually advocating
unhealthy behavior, that if
you eat donuts all the time,
you can get fat.
As if.
Anyway, I want to get
the read on all of this
from a guy who meant to do well.
Mike Tattersfield is
the Krispy Kreme CEO.
Mike, very good to have you.
The food police are
after you, Mike.
They don't like what you
seem to be advocating.
But I think you did also say
everything in moderation,
right?
We have.
I mean, if you think
about last year,
we did this thing
called acts of joy.
You and I chatted about
this about a year ago,
when we opened up to
the healthcare industry,
and they could get any donut, as
many as they wanted, any time.
We gave away 30 million
donuts last year in the US.
So you know, when
people make a choice--
as America gets a hold of the
pandemic and it's a personal
choice people make--
they look for-- if there's
a treat that they can get,
and we can serve it, it's great.
I've been actually in the shops.
So I was in Chicago and
Louisville this week.
And folks who show
me their CDC card.
And I go, you want that donut?
They're like, yes sir.
And they're really happy.
And it's just a little treat.
And it just shows the
generosity of the brand.
We are a sweet treat brand.
We get that.
Yeah.
And you know, I see
where you're coming here.
But you know, like people
are very creative, right?
They can come up with
ways to take advantage
of your good deed here.
Do you get a lot of customers
who go from Krispy Kreme
to Krispy Kreme, still showing
that proof of a vaccine?
I can't be the only
one doing that?
You know, we won't
make up our programs
for the folks that are going
to try to beat the system.
If that's what they
want to do, that's fine.
The generosity of the brand
is what we really stand for.
Now back to the issue that
obesity is a far bigger issue
in this country--
and this was raised
in the Washington Post today--
and that you should
be aware of that.
And they're lecturing you
on that because however
threatening you
look at the virus,
obesity kills tens
of thousands more
and that your product
leads to that.
You say?
You know, we're a
prod-- we're a donut.
And our brand actually serves
it primarily in dozens.
We're a sweet treat.
And it's shared.
People mostly use a
Krispy Kreme occasion,
and they share it
with their friends.
And the average American visits
a Krispy Kreme about four times
a year.
So I think we're OK there-- in
moderation, like anything else.
People will always
want a sweet treat.
They'll make their own judgment.
No, I think you're
right about that.
I just wanted to get
your take on all of that
because no good deed
goes unpunished.
People can push it.
But I'm going to warn Americans
that you really shouldn't
do what I've been doing
and go from Krispy Kreme
to Krispy Kreme,
because that's just--
You know, I'll be at the
shops, so maybe I'll find you.
I mean, I can tell you that
when I dropped off some donuts
at the vaccination
centers this week as well,
they just love it.
They're working hard.
So the least we could do
is just help them out.
Well, I'm getting word
because a lot of your stores
have photos of me saying,
had you seen this man?
And so we'll see what happens.
Have you gotten to
our flagship shop?
Mike Tattersfield of K--
yeah--
Have you made it
to the flagship--
--to Krispy Kreme--
--shop in New York?
No.
No, I haven't been
to the flagship shop.
But any way you can get
me there, I'm there.
So Mike--
You [INAUDIBLE].
--thank you very, very much.
All right, thank you
very much on this.